(audience applauding)
- All right, everybody.
We are back in it's American Heart Month.
Not long ago, my next guest
became an unlikely advocate
for heart health, when his
own heart began to fail.
You've seen him as
Lieutenant Randall Disher
on the long-running series,
"Monk".
He's joining us today,
thanks to a successful heart transplant.
Say hello to Jason Gray-Stanford.
(audience applauding)
(hip-hop music playing)
I'm a hugger.
- I heard you were a hugger.
- I know this has been killing me
'cause I have to like elbow people.
- Yeah.
- So--
- I know.
- Normal and weird.
- The crazy times we live in.
- I know, I know, at least
we're in the same room.
That's positive.
So I'd ask how you're feeling
but, well, you posted this video,
so let's see it real quick.
Like, I don't know if
anyone's ever done that.
- It's me putting in the
work with the W-E-R-K.
- Dude, I'm telling you.
(audience applauding)
First of all, you're making
those one things look easy.
That's hell on earth, my
man, I've done that before.
Those things are heavy.
- Yeah, well, I tell
you, it took a long time
to get back to that point.
- Yeah, I was gonna say, but you,
this is the interesting thing
that I love that people are gonna hear
because you are a fitness guy.
Like you had, you were like the picture
of health kind of walking around, right?
And then--
- Yeah, this is something
that really truly came
outta left field.
- Yeah.
- And, you know, hit you on a Tuesday
when you least expect it.
And I was.
About 2018, I was actually
working on a project,
and I actually, I was working
long hours as you do, right?
- Yeah.
- And when I was visiting friends,
kind of burning the candle at both ends,
and you know, sure enough,
I just felt a little off.
I thought it was the flu.
And I literally was like,
"Aagh, get over this, get some rest.
You'd be bounced right back".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But something in the
back of my mind was like,
"Give your doctor a call
'cause you're just about
to fly back home to Los Angeles".
And you know, I'm just not feeling right.
So I do, and he says, "You know what?
You should go get yourself,
just go get yourself checked out.
We wanna make sure you don't
have, you know, pneumonia
bronchitis or something.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, and so sure
enough I go to the doctors
and they wind up doing an EKG.
And that doctor comes in and says,
"Your heart's in a crazy arrhythmia.
You need to go to the
emergency room, now".
And the cardiologist comes in,
and basically after doing a
barrage of tests, you know,
kind of talks to me and says,
"You've got heart failure".
- And you're probably like,
"This is unbelievable,
I take care of myself."
- Once again.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Once again, to me,
it's almost ridiculous.
It's almost like I'm in denial.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like if you want the
truth, I'm like, come on.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm like, "No, no, I feel okay.
Let's go, I'll get outta here
and just get back to regular life".
But, you know, it was
stable for quite some time.
- With like medicine?
- With medication and
proper checkups, you know.
Come to the end of 2019,
I'm in a spin class,
and off I go, 20 minutes
later I wake up on the floor.
- [Kelly] That's scary.
- With the spin class, all looking at me.
And they basically rush
me to the emergency room.
And really from that point on,
it was kind of a rapid downhill descent.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That doctor comes back in and says,
"We have a donor heart for you.
We have one that's available now.
You have two hours to
decide if you want it".
So--
- That's such a big decision.
- That lands, yeah.
- Yeah.
And you know, and as I say,
you know, look at me,
I'm lucky to be sitting here
talking to you right now
because of it.
You know, and because of the--
- God bless the advances.
- 100%, I mean.
- Yeah.
- And the expertise of my
wonderful, wonderful doctors
and the nurses and all the staff.
And most importantly, to my donor
and the donor family who
without their selflessness
and kindness and generosity,
I mean, I ain't sitting here
talking to you right now,
doing this.
- Yeah.
- [Jason] Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- Now, we're gonna do this, yeah.
- It's pretty crazy.
- Well, Jason doesn't know this,
but we have one of the doctors
who played a big part in his
transplant journey on the line.
So let's everybody say hello
to the medical director
of heart transplants at St.
Paul's Hospital, Vancouver.
- When is he coming up?
There he is.
- Dr. Mustafa Toma.
(audience applauding)
- Dr. Toma.
Hi, how are you, sir?
- Jason, good to see you, man.
- Wonderful, wonderful to see you.
What a surprise.
They got me.
I had no idea this was coming.
- No, it's amazing what
you're capable of doing.
Like we were saying, the advances.
It's amazing that he's
able to live his life
at the selflessness of this donor,
but at the same time it's kind of amazing
that this person that was in
perfect health, basically,
ends up having heart problems.
Like, what do you think people
should take away from this?
- Well, I mean, as you guys probably know
heart disease is the number
one killer in north America.
And it's really never too late for people
or too early, to be honest,
to get their blood, their heart checked.
You know, they need to
start by exercising.
They need to watch sort of diet.
They need to see their family
doctor on a regular basis
and to make sure that their cholesterol
and their blood pressure
are all controlled.
And obviously they need
to listen to their body.
Jason is living proof
that heart disease can
affect young people as well.
And I think he did a great job
and really, he's really lucky
that he's sought medical attention
and look at where he is now.
- Yeah, absolutely.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
- I mean--.
- Yeah, well it's bitsy.
Hey, a lot of credit goes
to these guys, right there.
- No, absolutely.
But he is right.
- Dr. Toma and his team.
- But he is right though.
Also give yourself credit
'cause where I'm from, it's like,
unless you're like bleeding from your head
and like, can't move,
like you just take it.
Like where I'm from in the south,
it's like there, you know,
you're taught as a kid,
like, "You're fine, walk it off".
So it's important to really
be in tune with your body.
- It is absolutely.
And then Dr. Toma knows,
I asked a lot of questions
and I always kind of wanted
to be a part of the process
as best I could, you know, and--
- Watch your life.
- Yeah, 100%.
But I mean, as I say, you know,
just the care and the tact and the grace
and the expertise that I was provided,
was so comforting when you go
through a big kind of moment
like this.
It's a big deal, man.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, and I thank you, sir.
You know, and everybody, you know.
You pass it on to everybody
else up there who knows.
(audience applauding)
- A quick reminder, February
is American Heart Month
and a good time to
schedule a heart checkup.
If you didn't just hear this
story and you didn't hear that,
then listen, you just never
know and better safe than sorry.